FEMALE SPEAKER: So I'm
really excited to introduce
Joanne Chang.
She is the co-owner and pastry
chef at Flour Bakery + Cafe,
with four locations in
Boston and Cambridge,
as well as the co-owner
of Myers + Chang.
This is her third
visit our office,
and she has three cookbooks now.
So I'm looking forward to her
fourth visit to us maybe soon.
Please join me in welcoming
Joanne Chang up here
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
JOANNE CHANG: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Have a seat.
So I am really
excited that I get
to talk to you about this,
because I love to bake,
and it's something that I've
got to do since I was really,
I think, like eight years old.
And my parents never
really baked much,
so I started making cookies
and cakes and anything.
The low sugar thing
is interesting,
and it's been something
that I think a lot of people
are interested in
learning more about.
What made you start to decide
to do a cookbook about that?
JOANNE CHANG: It
certainly wasn't anything
that I had planned all along.
The first baking
book, "Flour," I'd
always wanted to
write a baking book.
The second book,
"Flour, Too," was
kind of a natural
offshoot of the first one,
because there are
a lot of people
who like to eat savory things.
And at the bakery, we do a
lot of sandwiches and soups
and salads.
And so after the
first book came out,
a lot of people, a
lot of our customers,
said, what happened to all of
the savory part of your menu?
So that led to the second book.
So this third book, "Baking with
Less Sugar," was not in my plan
until I started to think, OK,
next book, what should I do?
I really enjoy writing books,
and honestly, the next book
was supposed to be the
Myers + Chang book.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That'll
be your fourth visit.
JOANNE CHANG: That is going
to be the fourth visit,
and we did just sign a
deal for the fourth book.
So that one will be forthcoming.
But what happened
was I was starting
to write the proposal for
the Myers + Chang book,
and like two or three
things happened all at once.
One, at home, for
myself and my husband--
I eat sugar all day long.
That's part of my job,
to go to all the bakeries
and taste the
things that we make.
And fortunate for me, I don't
have a problem with sugar.
I've been eating it my
whole life, and I love it.
My husband loves
sugar, but he is
somebody who definitely goes
through sugar highs and sugar
lows.
I used to bring stuff home from
the bakery, and after eating it
he would just crash.
And I started to try
to figure out ways
that I could bring
stuff home or make stuff
at home that he could enjoy
and not feel deprived,
but that wouldn't cause him
to do this up and down thing.
So I was just starting to
experiment at home, just for me
personally.
At about the same time,
my publisher, Chronicle,
called me and said, OK,
we're interested in doing
a third book with you.
And I was like, great.
Myers + Chang?
And they said, no, we actually
think that a low sugar
book would be
something that people
would be really interested in.
I thought, OK, I'm
doing this at home.
This could be a thing.
I wasn't positive.
And then literally probably
about a week later,
"Oprah Magazine"
emailed and said,
we want you to write an
article about five desserts
with no sugar.
Can you do it?
And I just thought, this
is just meant to be.
It's a sign.
I don't know.
So I did these five
desserts for the magazine,
and I sent them to
Chronicle Books and I said,
what do you think?
And they said, this
is your next book.
So I spent about a
year testing recipes.
And this was really
challenging for me,
because the first two
books are all recipes that
currently exist.
They're things that we serve
every day at the bakery
that I have recipes for that
we make in huge batch sizes.
So with the first
and second book,
I just had to reduce
the batch size.
But for this third
book, I had to make up
recipes for pretty much
every single recipe,
to start from scratch.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, that was really
interesting to read
in your introduction
and throughout the book-- how
you were able to test recipes,
and the ones that
you thought might not
work, like the monkey bread
recipe that you said actually
did work.
And I haven't had a
chance to make it yet,
but it really good.
I'm actually curious if
there were any recipes
that you thought would work
or that you tried really
hard to make work that you just
couldn't get with low sugar.
JOANNE CHANG: Yeah, there's one
recipe that's still in my head,
because I still want to
try to figure it out.
So there's lemon pudding cake.
Have you ever had
lemon pudding cake?
It's a really easy cake batter.
you make this cake batter, you
put it in a pan, you bake it,
and naturally, the cake
part floats to the top,
and then at the bottom
is a layer pudding.
It's a really simple,
wonderful desert.
And I thought, I
would love to do
a low-sugar, no-sugar
version, but with maple syrup.
And I thought, maybe I could
make a maple pudding cake.
And I imagined this top
layer of cake floating
to the top that was
kind of like a pancake,
and then maybe like a creamy,
maple-y sauce at the bottom.
Doesn't that sound good?
I had the vision of what it was
going to taste like in my head.
I must have made maple
pudding cake like every week
probably for the whole year.
I feel like it was about the
whole year of writing the book,
and it just kept
being that recipe
that I was like, I'm going
to try it again next week.
I'm going to try
it again next week.
I never got it.
I think what happens is
you have to do something
with the eggs that involves
sugar that doesn't work
with maple in order to get
the pudding to the sink
and the cake to rise.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That brings me
to an interesting question too,
is the science behind sugar.
And there were other
things like meringues
that you said you knew
you couldn't really
even bother doing.
Could you tell us a little
bit about what low-sugar means
in this cookbook, and maybe also
a little bit about the science
behind sugar and how it helps
make certain things work
the way they do in baking?
JOANNE CHANG: So I thought
that the biggest challenge
in writing this book was
going to be figuring out
how to replicate the sweetness
in desserts, because you're
eliminating sugar.
Because that's what we
think of as sugar, right?
It's sweet.
So if you have something
that has less sugar,
it's going to be less sweet.
So how do I trick the palate
into thinking that it still
tastes sweet?
But that ended up being the
easiest part of the book,
in part because we
are very adaptable.
And it works with salt,
and it works with sugar.
If you go without salt or
if you go without sugar,
I don't know the exact time
it takes, but after a while
your palate just starts to
naturally prefer the less
salt or the less sugar.
And it's the same with
more salt and more sugar.
The more you eat of sugar
and the more you eat of salt,
the more your palate
adjusts to that,
and then you want things that
are more sugary or more salty.
So that part was easy
in that once I started
testing these recipes
with less sugar, for me,
I recognized that things
that were less sweet
tasted just as
good, if not better.
But the challenging part
was the chemistry of sugar,
because sugar does so many
other things than just sweeten.
The main-- well, there's
a bunch of main things,
but one of the big
things that sugar does
is it's hygroscopic,
which means that it
attracts moisture in the air.
And so it attracts water.
And so in any baked good
that has sugar in it,
it sits there on the counter,
and as it's sitting there
it's attracting water
molecules from the air
and bringing it to itself.
And that's what makes
the pastry stay moist
for a couple of days.
So you can make a
cake today and still
serve it tomorrow
or the next day,
and it'll still
be great if it has
the regular amount of sugar.
As you start to
reduce sugar, it'll
taste great when it's
fresh out of the oven.
And then maybe by tonight
or maybe by tomorrow
it's dry, because it doesn't
have the sugars to draw
in all the moisture.
Another thing that sugar
does is that it caramelizes
is when it's in the oven.
And so when you're making
something like a cookie,
the sugar combines with all
of the other ingredients
in the batter, and then
it hits that oven heat
and then it starts
to caramelize.
And that's what
allows the cookie
to be kind of crunchy
on the outside
and then maybe a little
soft on the inside.
So it's really challenging
to get texture right
when you don't have sugar,
or if you have less sugar.
I think that was a
really big challenge.
Another thing that
sugar does which
is kind of in line
with the caramelization
is that it adds
color to baked goods.
And so any picture-- if you
imagine a beautiful vanilla
cake, you just see
like golden brown.
Every recipe says,
bake till golden brown.
But you can't bake
things till golden brown
if there's no sugar, because
it'll never get that way.
And that was, for
me, something that
took me awhile to recognize.
I was making the carrot
cake, which is actually
the cover photo in the book.
And the carrot cake doesn't
have any sugar in it,
but it has apple juice.
It has reduced apple juice.
And I kept making this batter
and testing it and tasting it
and saying, OK, it
tastes sweet enough,
putting it into the oven.
And then I do everything by eye.
I don't do it by time,
because ovens are different,
and everything's
always different.
So at this point, I just look
at things and I touch them.
And the first couple
rounds of this cake,
I would keep it in there
until it got brown,
which it turns out
was pretty much burnt,
because it doesn't
brown without the sugar.
And so when you pull it out of
the oven, it looks really pale.
It looks the same color
as it did when it goes in.
It's just a little
bit more solid.
So you have to get used
to that when you're not
baking with as much sugar.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
really liked the way you
have the chapters organized.
It starts with the
lower sugar recipes
and then goes into just
chocolate, honey, maple,
and then fruit.
What was your reasoning behind
organizing it in that way?
JOANNE CHANG: Well, I wanted
to ease people into the idea.
So the first chapter is
probably about 10 or 12 recipes
of things that we all
eat every day that have
less sugar-- so not no-sugar.
So the fudgy mascarpone
brownies that I made,
the banana bread,
yellow birthday cake,
coconut chiffon cake-- all of
those have white sugar in them,
but at least half
the amount or even
less than your standard recipe.
So I wanted to just
kind of introduce
the baker, or the
reader, to the idea
that you can reduce
sugar and still have
something that tastes great.
In fact, we have samples of
the oatmeal raisin walnut
cookie that is made with a
third of the amount of sugar
as the standard recipe.
So that was the first chapter.
And then, in terms of grouping
it according to flavors--
you asked earlier why did
I want to write the book,
and I give you a
couple of reasons.
Another reason is that sugar
itself doesn't actually
taste like anything.
It's just sweet.
Whereas sweeteners like
maple and honey and fruit
actually have flavor, and they
add a whole other dimension
of flavor to whatever it
is that you're making.
And a big part of
writing this book
was recognizing that
if you don't use sugar
as your sweetener
but instead turn
to a natural sweetener like a
honey or a maple or molasses,
you're adding that flavor
to your baked good, which
is in my world a
really great thing.
You have something
that tastes good
and you add more flavor to it.
That's even better.
So I wanted to group
it accordingly,
so that if you're somebody
who really likes honey
and if you like that
flavor of honey,
here's a whole bunch
of recipes that
allow you to use that
rather than white sugar
in making your baked goods.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
And I told you I made the
lemon ricotta cupcakes, which
are just sweetened with honey.
And it was great,
and you would never
have known that
the frosting even
didn't have any sugar in it.
It was great.
So I did notice that the only
cheesecake recipe in here
is cheesecake maple bar,
something like that?
JOANNE CHANG: The pumpkin?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, pumpkin.
That's what it was.
Was there any reason that
you didn't-- I happen to love
cheesecake, so first I'm
asking about cheesecake.
Was there any reason
you didn't do just
a regular, straight-up
cheesecake, or just as it
happened?
JOANNE CHANG: No, no reason.
I wanted to do
something with pumpkin,
and we've often talked
about introducing a pumpkin
cheesecake during the
Thanksgiving period
at the bakery.
And so I was thinking that
we could do something.
I mean, pumpkin goes
well with maple,
but we already have in the
book a maple pumpkin pie.
So then I got really
interested and excited
about baking with dates.
And so this recipe
has dates in the base,
and then the actual
cheesecake is
sweetened with reduced
apple juice, which
is one of the go-to's
in the fruit chapter.
Again, you bring in
so many more flavors
when you are working with
fruits versus just with sugar.
And I wanted to try out
mixing apple and pumpkin,
and it all worked out great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
So again, we were
talking about this
before-- I had thought about
going to culinary school
for pastry arts at one point.
Almost dropped out of
grad school to do it,
and decided instead
not to, in part
because I was worried
that if I did something
that I loved doing at
home and on my own time
all the time for work,
I wouldn't enjoy it
as much anymore.
So do you still like baking?
JOANNE CHANG: I
still love baking.
I don't make as much
as I used to, for sure.
The first six years of the
bakery, I was baking every day.
And then when we opened
the second location,
my role shifted so that I
was no longer in the kitchen
every single day.
But I still in the kitchen
probably about half the time.
And then when we opened
Cambridge, the third location,
then it shifted entirely
out of the kitchen.
So I bake now when I'm
testing recipes for a book,
and I'll bake at home just
for special occasions.
It's still something
that I enjoy,
but as somebody who
if you enjoy baking
and you want to do
it professionally--
not that I think you guys are
looking for career changes,
but if you were-- it
is very, very different
to do it professionally.
It's a job.
It's still work.
We get a lot of people, a lot of
career changers, who come to us
and say, I bake a lot at
home and I really love it,
and I want to come learn how
to make cookies at Flour.
And everybody loves it for
about two weeks, sometimes
three weeks, and then
the reality hits in.
It's like, every day
you're going to come in
and you're going to
crack 20 flats of eggs,
and then you're going to do
this, and nothing changes.
There's just a lot of detail
and work, and it's hard
and it's sweaty.
It's still work.
So when you're baking
at home, you obviously
have freedom to do
whatever you want.
You get to eat it
whenever you want.
And if it doesn't
work out, no big deal.
You just make something else.
Doesn't really work
like that at work.
So I always try to make people
understand that it's still
really fun to bake at
work, but it's just
a different type of fun.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sure.
So my last question before
we open it up to the audience
is we have backyard hens.
And so I often
have a refrigerator
full of two, three dozen eggs.
What's your favorite recipe
that uses a lot of eggs?
JOANNE CHANG: Let's see,
recipes that use a lot of eggs.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sweet
or savory, either way.
JOANNE CHANG: Well,
it would be sweet.
The chiffon cake that's
in this book actually,
or any angel food
cake or chiffon cake
is great for using
a lot of eggs.
The angel food cake in the first
book, I think, uses 12 eggs,
and I think this cake
might use 8 or 12 eggs.
Any custard basically is going
to use a lot of egg yolks.
So in pastry, you're always
using egg yolks for the most
part, and you're always
trying to find something
to do with the egg whites.
So I feel like ice creams
use a lot of egg yolks,
and then meringues and
chiffon cakes and angel food
cakes use a lot of egg whites.
So you can make two.
FEMALE SPEAKER: An angel food
cake and a giant custard.
JOANNE CHANG: Exactly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So if there
are questions in the audience,
there are microphones
set up in the aisles.
Please.
AUDIENCE: When you
experiment with cooking,
do you remember any really
big surprises where you didn't
think two things were going
to complement each other
or go together, and they
ended up being great?
JOANNE CHANG: In
baking, you mean?
I do mostly dabbling
around in baking.
Let's see, two things that
combined that came out great.
Well, I was surprised
at this pumpkin thing--
pumpkin and apple.
Even though pumpkin pie
and apple pie sound good,
I've never had
pumpkin apple pie.
So when I was doing
the cheesecake,
I was trying to figure
out if-- I mean,
it's a double-edged sword.
You're adding the flavor
of apple to anything
that you sweeten with
apple juice, which
is great, unless it
doesn't go well with apple.
So that actually ended
up being really great,
because pumpkin is
really rich and earthy,
and apple is kind of acidic.
And so I often feel like
when I'm eating pumpkin,
I want something a little
bit brighter anyway.
And so by sweetening the pumpkin
with a little bit of apple,
for me it's a much more
rounded, balanced dessert.
So that was something
that I wasn't expecting.
AUDIENCE: You were talking about
having to experiment about how
white sugar is hygroscopic.
And I was just curious,
did you play at all
with temperature for
things like baking cakes
or whatnot at the
end so you could
try and trap the
water at the tail-end
of the cooking process?
JOANNE CHANG: Well, we did
experiment with a temperature,
just because there are things
that you still need them
to bake, but they don't brown.
And so you're kind of adjusting.
And anything with
honey or maple,
you want to bake it a little bit
less, lower temperature anyway.
But the hygroscopic
is for when it's done,
and then it's sitting
on the counter
or on the shelf or whatever.
That's when that element
comes into play more
than in the baking in the oven.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So throwing it in the
freezer at the end
wouldn't necessarily
help capture
the water inside of the cake?
JOANNE CHANG: No, it would.
If you had a cake and
you wanted to delay
that evaporation
or the drying, you
could definitely slow it down
by putting it in the freezer,
for sure.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
And my question's
not about less sugar,
but one of my favorite treats
at Flour are the vegan muffins.
You have a vegan vanilla berry
and a vegan banana chocolate
chip.
And then any time I eat a
vegan treat anywhere else,
it's really dry and gross.
So I don't know
if it's a secret--
JOANNE CHANG: I didn't pay
her to say that, I swear.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know if it's a secret,
but I've always
wondered what you
do with your vegan treats
to make them taste just as
good as some of the other ones?
JOANNE CHANG: Well, thank you.
The vegan muffin recipe is in
the second book, "Flour, too."
I don't know what
other people are doing,
but we just
substitute the things
that-- I mean, if you're
vegan, then you already know.
Like instead of milk, we use
soy milk or coconut milk.
Instead of butter, we use oil.
We didn't do anything
for the instead of eggs.
I think we just kind
of fiddled around
with the oil and the milk to
make it still liquid enough.
But I don't know that we
did anything that magical.
There's no magic to it.
It's in the book.
When we do come up
with a new recipe,
we spend a lot of
time experimenting.
Everything is weighed
at the bakery.
Everything is
weighed to the gram,
and we will literally change
things by 1% to 2% iteration
after iteration to get to
where we want it to be.
In fact, there's an
email thread going
on right now about
something that they're like,
should we up it 3%?
And I was like, nope,
let's start with 3%.
Let's try it first just 3%, and
then we'll see what happens.
So there's a lot of testing.
So the recipe for
the vegan muffin
that you're talking about
went through many rounds
of maybe it started
out dry at one point,
and then we just added
more and more stuff.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOANNE CHANG: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Joanne.
Thanks so much for coming today.
Curious if you can talk a
little bit about your process
for testing recipes
for a cookbook,
and if there's like an average
number of times you test,
if you throw it to other
people to test to make sure
it's accessible for
the novice baker.
JOANNE CHANG: Sure.
So if it's a recipe
that we already
have, like the
vegan muffin recipe,
which exists at the bakery,
basically what happens
is-- so everything's
in metric, and I just
reduce it to what seems like
a normal home size amount.
And then I'll test it myself.
And I'll go through it once.
But just because I
can do it, I know
that that doesn't mean that it's
ready for the book, because I
know what I'm
thinking, so I need
to give it to somebody else.
So then a baker will test
it within the bakery,
just to make sure that it's
kind of the right thing.
But even that doesn't
really work from a testing
perspective, because
all the bakers know me,
and they know what I mean
when I say, do this, do that.
So then we send it out.
Cambridge Culinary will
test recipes for us
for class credit.
And so depending on
whatever semester,
I'll reach out to the
director and she'll put me
in touch with that class.
And they are on my
email list, and I say,
here's a bunch of
recipes I need tested.
And then I have a couple
testers who are just people
that I've worked closely
with who just test for me.
If it's something that
already exists at the bakery,
it doesn't take that
many iterations,
because we already do it.
It's just a matter
of figuring out--
like sometimes as you
reduce, reduce, reduce,
it reduces to a weird number.
It reduces to like 1 cup plus
2 tablespoons and 1 teaspoon.
And that's not
really that usable,
so I'll have to change
things around and change
the proportions around just to
make sure that somebody at home
can actually do it.
But that usually takes
like one, maybe two tries.
But if it's a brand-new recipe,
like with the low sugar book,
I feel like those
recipes, a good recipe
would take four
iterations by me.
So that's me trying it out
and then adjusting, adjusting,
adjusting, and then by the
fourth time being like,
OK, I think this works.
Then I would give it to a baker
and then they would do it.
And usually, again, it
was almost the same thing
as my doing it.
They know me well enough
that they would just make it.
So that's like a fifth test.
And then when we would
send it out to the testers.
And usually from there,
I would say about 80%
of the time it worked and 20%
of the time I'd get feedback
like, this isn't really working.
So then we'd adjust it.
But by then, it was
usually just one iteration,
because I would get specific
feedback and I would say,
ah, I knew that that
was going to happen.
Let me adjust this.
So that's a good recipe.
A bad recipe-- or
not a bad recipe.
No bad recipes.
A more challenging
recipe, probably more
like eight or nine times.
Again, because we're doing
things in such small--
in pastry, there are so many
things that you can vary,
right?
If you have 10 ingredients in
your thing, in your recipe,
and you're trying to make
it more moist or less
sweet or whatever, if you
just adjust one thing,
it's going to affect
everything else.
So what you want to do
is adjust everything,
but then you don't know which
one of those adjustments worked
and which one doesn't.
So you have to kind of go
slowly and say, well, I'm
just going to reduce the eggs
from four eggs to three eggs
and see what happens.
Then you have to wait till
it bakes, wait till it cools,
try it, and then do it again.
So it takes a lot of patience,
but it's a lot of fun.
And there's a lot of
mistakes along the way
that most people don't
view as mistakes.
So people like to
eat the mistakes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If you need to
testers for your next cookbook,
I'd be happy to send
recipes out to the office.
Our office is very
good with feedback.
JOANNE CHANG: If you guys
want to test recipes, sure.
AUDIENCE: I wondered
about convection oven
versus conventional,
and which is your go-to
and in what cases will you opt
for the other choice, and why?
JOANNE CHANG: We use mostly
convection at this point,
but it's for specific pastries.
So for cookies,
brioche, muffins,
and tarts, tart shells,
we'll use convection.
And we'll use deck ovens,
or the still ovens,
for things like bread and cakes.
And the difference--
with the convection,
you've got the fan
whirring around,
which is making the
temperature more consistent,
but it is introducing the
element of movement and air.
And so for a cookie or a
brioche or something that's
relatively stable, I
don't mind that there's
air blowing around, because
I just want it to bake,
and I want it to bake
relatively evenly.
I don't want half
of the brioche to be
under and half to be over.
But a cake-- if you put a cake
in a convection oven, what
tends to happen is that the cake
starts to cook on the outside,
because you've got
this whirring fan.
And then the inside is
still needing time to cook.
And so the cake will
sometimes come out
crispier on the outside.
It'll finish baking on the
outside first, and by the time
the inside is baked it'll be
over-baked on the outside.
So we have found
that the still ovens
are better for baking cakes,
because it's slow, steady heat.
There's no air that's trying
to basically form a crust.
And that's the same with bread.
If you put bread in
the convection oven,
the air will cause the skin
of the bread to crust, which
means that as the yeast
is trying to expand
and as the bread's trying
to get big and airy,
it can't because it's
been crusted over.
So we prefer doing
that in a still oven.
And then even better is if you
can inject some steam in it--
take a little water bottle and
put some steam-- it creates
a really humid
environment for the bread,
so then the bread dough stays
supple as the yeast is growing.
And then it doesn't crust over
until the yeast are all dead,
and then you get
that crust that's
characteristic of
really good bread.
So that's how we differentiate.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
JOANNE CHANG: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I had a question
about how you
decide which recipes to share.
Do you have a
collection of recipes
that you're never going to share
that are like the secret ones?
JOANNE CHANG: Nope.
The first book was
all the recipes
that we had at the time.
And then since then,
we've done new things.
And people will say, how come
you didn't share this recipe?
And I'll say, because we
hadn't made it at that point.
And the same with
the second book.
I put a bunch of salads
in the second book,
and then we came up with a
new salad menu at the bakery,
and everyone's like, where's
the Green Goddess dressing?
And I said, oh, we
hadn't made it by then.
So the issue for us now is if
somebody wants a recipe that
hasn't been tested.
I can give you the recipe to
make like 10 gallons of Green
Goddess, and if you want
to do the math-- or I
can do the math as well and
just give it to you in grams.
But I don't have home-friendly
recipes for everything,
so that's usually
the limiting factor.
If somebody says,
I love this recipe.
I'll just say to them, I can
give it to you in the big batch
and I can do the math, just
divided it by 50 or whatever.
But depending on
your comfort level,
you can either use it
or it won't really help.
So I don't really
feel like recipes
are meant to be-- I feel like
recipes are meant to be shared.
A lot of that
comes from the fact
that we obviously use the same
recipe at the bakery for all
of our items.
Every baker has access
to the big recipe book.
And it's crazy
the variation that
comes, even though
everything is weighed
to the gram and everything is
timed almost to the second.
And yet, we will still
have huge variations.
Because to me, baking
isn't just about-- I mean,
everyone talks about
how baking is chemistry
and it's so precise.
And it is, but it's also
so much about who you are
and what you put into it, and
how you're feeling that day.
I know this sounds
very touchy-feely,
but I really feel like
pastry is something
that you can tell if
somebody's doing it right
and doing it well.
And so giving somebody the
recipe isn't the secret.
It's all the
thought and the care
and the attention that goes into
making it that's the secret.
So I'm happy to
share all the recipes
and hope that everybody has
that same thought and care.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOANNE CHANG: You're welcome.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think we're
out of audience questions.
I love that last
thing that you said,
because I've always said
that my art is baking
and that I put love into
everything that I make.
And so I do that
for gifts for people
for holidays and everything,
so it was awesome
that you said that.
Thank you so much for coming.
JOANNE CHANG: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]